all right let's go
to atlanta georgia where matt joins us
matt how can we help
how you doing christian man we are
living the dream how are you sir
i'm finally living the dream brother but
uh i have to demolish this real quick
in 2012 i was making four hundred
thousand dollars a year
wow i'm an oil business blowing in on
women and
when the oil market crashed they end up
sleeping in a 1982 car i lost
all my mercedes out paying 500 a month
for a condo
and i want to go to rv and i slept in it
for three years
now i'm back to 300 000 again and i
don't want to buy a house everything i
bought is cash my trucks are paid for
cash
i paid i owe child support i paid 80 000
with the child support off the two
mothers
debt-free my credit score is like 800
and i don't want to buy a house
because i'm so afraid of what i've been
through um so do you want us to talk you
out of that decision
or is there a place it's just like well
i i want to go get an apartment
but i'm like okay that's a waste of
money i was going to buy a house
yesterday on
auction.com for 80 000 but i said okay i
could go buy another truck and make more
money with that i make more money with
myself
than anybody ever pay me an interest but
you kind of get my point when do you
pull yourself out of this rv and go back
into the living yeah
and i'm not sure when you do that do you
like living in the rv
i i did for three years but it's getting
old now you you know you got money in
the bank
yeah you know people look at me like
these crap you know i got a brand new
outing
it's not brand new but it's a couple of
years old i paid it's probably worth 20.
i caught a guy who nearly needed it i
paid him 13 000 cash for it so you have
no
debt is that right matt i have
absolutely no
how much do you have in the bank account
matt
uh 180 000 and if and i got some for my
reserves i would probably say 225.
okay and as you look at this is do you
do do you have any money toward
retirement or anything at all
hey see that that's that's what my
problem is i don't have any money toward
retirement okay
but i feel like this is where i really
feel if i i probably got 200
almost 300 thousand dollar equipment i
can sell that when i
finally close my business but you can't
guarantee that no i feel like it'd be
worth a hell of a lot more
what kind of business hey what do you do
for a living matt
i do uh chemicals fields and clean up
okay
all right okay i would say listen are
you going to be
in the atlanta area for the next three
years
definitely are you going to stay in that
business
uh yes and i'm trying to go into other
things because what happened the last
time i was just in the oil business and
i never want to get caught in one
business again
okay well and here's the thing you got
ptsd
all right from what happened in the past
and here's what i want to warn you from
you are it i love the mindset of having
the cash mentality
what i don't want you to do is is don't
try to make up for what happened to you
by going back to it
and that's over leveraging yourself i
don't think there's anything wrong with
you buying a modest home
you can put 20 down you can go into that
knowing exactly where you are you always
want to keep that three to six month
emergency fund
but inside of your business you also
want to operate to where you have what's
called
uh reserves um and so
matt you need to get out of the rv okay
you need to get out of the rv
hold on a second hold on hold on chris
because my friends are beginning to
laugh at me about like
i'm not worried about them i'm not
worried about them i'm just talking
about for you to be able to put down
some roots so matt
i'm gonna ask chris a question on your
behalf uh-oh yeah all right i'm trying
to help them in come on all right you've
been getting good advice i got questions
all right are you a sole proprietor matt
yes okay doesn't he need to set up like
a sep or something in his business and
then
also personally he can i guess what i'm
what's the advice
uh for him to get caught up and not
completely caught up but the guy's got a
lot of money in the bank he's got a lot
of money sitting and he's
making good money how does he get the
retirement yeah so it's not growing for
him so
for him he's got an opportunity to be
able as a self-employed person he can do
a sep
he can do a solo 401k he can invest in
gross stock mutual funds
so him starting to put some money aside
so that gross ram is going to be huge
what he said was is that at the end of
the day he knows he could sell his
equipment
maybe and get x y and z well that's the
exit strategy that's not a retirement
strategy
so it's important for him as this money
is coming in yeah that he's go he's got
roots
but he can start to invest money each
and every so matt listen you're making
really good money
so chris does he set up a sep and then
also when he pays himself so the sep
is what his company will put into
retirement for him that's him doing it
he's going to be doing this himself
and then he can additionally make up
some more ground yep you can put aside
listen with the income you have coming
in you can start to really make some
strides my friend
you know remaining allergic now listen
watch this ken
matt how many vehicles do you own right
now outside of the business
uh i just have my car just but i have
two work trucks just one car
okay all right i was gonna say i felt
like you were gonna tell me you had a
truck a car
maybe a motorcycle no i just i i felt
like you know i had
punished for that that 82 has broke my
heart just you know
you know i had a i know 2013 mercedes
paid for
and have to have a car that's worth 900.
matt how much
matt how much is your rv worth if you
sell it today
uh eight grand maybe ten oh okay all
right okay
but i want you to do this i want you to
again make a decision
either a get an apartment right uh or
townhouse or somewhere to live or if
you're serious about a house go ahead
and do that
but i want you to get connected with the
smart investor pros so you start to lay
out an
investing plan for you in the future uh
glance back brother but focus forward
and i mean glance back and look at what
happened and yeah the mercedes you can
you can you can get you another one of
those right the main thing
that's good i don't blame you
they're expensive you can burn one time
brother you don't have to get burnt for
once that's why i love you and dave
man because i before i even heard of
dave i was going through this
and then to hear you all telling other
people exactly what i'm going through
myself
you all are helping a lot of people well
i'm going to tell you you calling in and
talking about what you've lived through
is also going to help some people
uh because we all have to grow forward
my friend and that's exactly what you've
done
and matt listen be encouraged man what
you have come
through and you have fixed it and you're
back on your way
i mean he has done a tremendous job i
think matt what what you need to hear
from chris
is chris is saying look you're not going
to do that again you've experienced that
you've experienced the pain and you're
worried about causing pain
for yourself that you know you're never
going to do again so
get going forward here uh your best days
are
still ahead and uh hang on the line
kelly let's give him a copy of chris's
book the number one bestselling book
everyday millionaires there's so much
good stuff in there that will just
encourage you because that's where
you're heading next matt
you are on your way